elles étaient venues de partout par cars
par trains spéciaux pour exiger dans les
rues de paris
un statut et de meilleurs salaires les
infirmières ont manifesté en masse
aujourd'hui à l'appel de la coordination
et de la cgt qui avait organisé le plus
gros cortège à l'appel aussi de
l'intersyndicale qui manifestaient
séparément
le ministre de la santé claude evin
continue en ce moment de négocier avec
les syndicats mais déjà la coordination
qu'il avait rencontré plus tôt dans
l'après-midi appelle à la poursuite de
la grève jusqu'à lundi
françois joly et christophe martet dix
élèves infirmières des infirmières
confirmé et même des professeurs de
renom comme les autres albert michel
boisrond pour les soutenir
elle était ce matin à paris près de
100000 venus de toute la france à
l'appel de la coordination des
infirmières
oui
les syndicats eux n'ont pas réussi leur
pari faire aussi bien que la
coordination des infirmières tout
personnel hospitalier confondues dix
mille personnes seulement ont défilé cet
après-midi le poids de la coordination
dans cette mobilisation ce que nous
reprochons à la coordination c'est de ne
s'intéresser qu'aux seuls actionnaires
les l'hôpital n'est pas seulement les
infirmières c'est aussi six cent
cinquante mille autres personnels 14h30
claude evin en personne reçoit les
dirigeants de la coordination
il précise les propositions de ces
derniers jours une augmentation de 500
francs pour les infirmières en début de
carrière avec à terme une revalorisation
de leur salaire de 1000 francs à sa
sortie la coordination adopte un ton
mesuré la pression qui s'exerce
actuellement au niveau du du mouvement
infirmier a considérablement fait
progresser les choses
ceci étant dit rien n'est figé pour
l'instant mais la base elle ne l'entend
pas de cette oreille
très mobilisés en fin d'après-midi les
manifestantes en décidé la poursuite du
mouvement de grève pour demain et samedi
depuis un peu plus d'une heure ce soir
ici au ministère de la santé les
négociations ont repris entre les
syndicats et le ministre claude evin
les syndicats attendent les ultimes
propositions du ministre le gouvernement
lui semble décidé à aller très vite
maintenant pour éteindre ce conflit
avant qu'il ne se propage à toutes les
professions de la santé